[Music]
i think the one common thing right now
that people want to see
is community like women empowerment
i think people want to see love and
that's exactly what they'll get when
caitlyn joins tasha adams to act as
katie's mentor
on the new season of the bachelorette
there was a few times where i'm like
can i even air this because i'm just
saying it how it is like you know what i
mean it was really nice to
to be there as a mentor and support
system caitlyn herself of course
recently got engaged to fellow bachelor
nation alum jason tardik
and she's definitely got babies on the
brink is that something you've been
thinking about soon after the wedding
you want to wait a little bit
i do have my eggs frozen so i'm not like
the biological clock is not
exactly ticking but i do you know want
to really think about that just because
i have met my person we are getting
married and so i do feel like that next
step
quickly after is gonna be having a
family
well lance bass is about to embark on
another kind of game for two
taking on first time fatherhood to twins
with husband michael churchin
the couple tells people magazine they're
expecting a boy and a girl via surrogate
this november
after years of unsuccessful attempts in
fact their previous surrogate suffered a
miscarriage
just last summer but now the guys
couldn't be more excited
as they share the news on tick tock with
this horror themed announcement
michael look